pendant mon enfant tous les cas le temps
des vacances est arrivé pour nombre de
parents ce temps des vacances c'est
aussi vous le savez celui des casse tête
que faire des jeunes garçons ou bien des
jeunes filles en attendant départ à la
campagne ou à la mère de juillet ou bien
du mois d'août
alors quand il fait beau on va y a pas
trop de problème on peut toujours aller
faire du sport mais quand il pleut il ne
reste plus que le cinéma
seulement voilà la production des films
pour le jeune public reste faible en
france et les salles spécialisées ne
sont pas assez nombreuses sont encore en
vacances et que le temps est incertain
le cinéma bien sûr une solution
seulement voilà tous les parents le
savent il n'est pas si facile de trouver
des cinémas des films aux enfants à
paris mais mes salles spécialisées se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main
malgré les coûts importantes qui se
forment le mercredi ou le dimanche
et c'est là le problème deux jours par
semaine ce n'est pas assez répondent les
distributeurs les propriétaires de
salles le cinéma pour enfants ce n'est
pas rentable en dehors des congés
scolaires
on se contente donc d'exploiter quelques
valeurs sûres comme les production walt
disney est ce suffisant
je souhaite à qui des films dans les
acteurs c'est un jeu pour les enfants
quand mu malone que j'ai bien aimé tu
n'as pas de salles spécialisées pour en
prendre ton quartier moi j'aimerais
canet au moins une part par
arrondissement pour que les enfants
puissent y accéder plus facilement
vendons de barbe noire
il veut vous faire mourir mais de rire
seulement hissé le pavillon noir
alou de 24 mille sabords pittoresque il
avait un fantôme qui se déchaînent les
aristochats ou robin des bois ont fait
citer en france plus de 4 millions de
jeunes spectateurs
mais en dehors des grands circuits
commerciaux les tentatives sont rares et
souvent décevante exemple l'expérience
des petits poucet montmartre et saint
dominique
il y avait soit cinéma porno ça ne
m'intéresse pas soit le cinéma d'art et
d'essai nous faisons depuis 15 ans mais
là aussi les circuits nous ont pris une
partie de notre clientèle et de notre
new films et nous restait le cinéma pour
enfants
alors depuis trois ans on en fait avec
plus ou moins d'enthousiasmé plutôt
moins maintenant qu'au début au début
nous avions demandé la collaboration du
jeune personne qui était chargée de
contacter tous les directeurs et
directrices d'établissements scolaires
aux environs chargé de créer un fichier
pour faire venir pour informer les
enfants des manifestations que nous
avions envie de faire
et puis petit à petit on sert tellement
difficultés que nous nous contentons
maintenant de programme est très
régulièrement les quatre ou cinq films
qui sont dans le commerce il ya un vaste
public est un public qui n'est jamais vu
chez eux que je regrette beaucoup ce
public des enfants quand ils sont à
l'école je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
directeurs d'établissements scolaires
mais nous contacter jean jamais
contrairement à ce que nous avons tenté
de faire pour nous dire écoutez vous
avez une grande salle
on aimerait réunir cinq ou six classes
jeudi après midi un vendredi après-midi
que peut-on faire ce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose ensemble de patience ne
soit pas trop cher face à la dimension
mondiale de walt disney la production
française de films destinés aux jeunes
paraît très pauvre manque d'audace et
d'imagination sans doute avec peau d'âne
jacques demy est l'un des seuls metteur
en scène français avoir tenté quelque
chose
l'industrie du cinéma est un une
industrie en crise là en ce moment
en plus fait qu' on essaie de faire des
films pour tout public et qui a toujours
des compromis de toutes sortes et je
sais que quand je voulu faire peau d'âme
par exemple je crois que j'ai pu le
faire parce que c'est un film qui
s'adressait précisément aussi bien aux
adultes qu'aux enfants restent donc les
films pour adultes qui peuvent être vus
par les enfants c'est pour les
distinguer qu'a été créé le label
chouette
est ce que c'est ça la belle chouette
c'est un label qui est destiné à vous
dire quels sont les films que vous
pouvez voir en dehors de ce que vous
irez voir de toute façon la castagne je
suis sûr que vous arrêterez devant ce
n'est pas chouette c'est pas votre
problème et vous vous arrêterez le
fantôme de barbe noire je suis sûr que
vous vous arrêterez est ce que vous
savez que omar gatlato est un film
algérien est une merveille pour vous est
ce que vous savez que en route pour la
gloire qui vient d'être présenté à
cannes est un merveilleux chine pour
vous non plus est ce que vous savez à
londres des mois sa mémoire
la guerre la musique et nous vous avez
entendu parler toi donc même pas un fou
rire et création il s'est pourtant
formidable et le diable dans la boîte
message entendu ça oui ça vous avez
envie d'y aller voyez pourtant c'est un
film sur un sujet d'adultes terriblement
adulte est formidable vous allez vous
allez adorer ça mais pourquoi ne pas
demander aux enfants de choisir eux
mêmes c'est ce qui a été fait au dernier
festival d'avoriaz un jury d'enfants
imprimer le bus en folie encore une
production américaine dont la sortie est
prévue le 15 juin
souhaitons-lui d'inspirer enfin des
réalisateurs français